Courtney is just pointed
out that today's November,
the 17th significance
of which had evaded me,
but it's the [inaudible] session day of
Elizabeth the first she would have been
greeted in the 16th and 17th centuries
with bell ringing and so forth.
It's no longer kept as a national holiday,
but it used to be okay.
But today we have other business,
um,
the restoration and the run up to the
so called glorious revolution of 1688.
So to start, um, the restoration of,
of May,
1660 clearly represented a fresh
start for the Monica in England,
but it was a fresh start that has to
be understood against the background of
past events,
which could not be forgotten even though
people tried hard not to talk about
them.
The constitutional crisis
of 1640 had of course,
a risen from a functional breakdown in
the relationship between the crown and
the political nation,
a breakdown traceable ultimately to their
loss of confidence in the purposes of
royal government.
And the fear in particular that royal
policy was favoring Potpourri and
arbitrary power.
Initially that crisis of 1640 to 41 had
led to the successful efforts of the
long parliament to reverse the trend in
royal policy and to put limits on the
king for the future.
A civil war of course had to be
fought to try to preserve those gains.
And in the course of the war,
further dimensions of the situation
emerged no to bleed the demand for liberty
of conscience. So in all of
that, as I described last week,
the one political moment which might
have produced a broadly acceptable
settlement had been in 1647
when Cromwellian Diet and
offered Charles the heads
of the proposals as the basis for
a settlement. But as you know,
that moment was lost with disastrous
consequences for the king.
Well,
the restoration has to be seen in this
context of well remembered events.
It was intended to restore the situation
to what it had been in 1641 after the
reforming statutes of the long parliament
with the addition of the granting of
some liberty of conscience
to Protestant dissenters,
which Charles the second had promised
in his declaration of Breeder.
And if this had happened,
it might indeed have provided
a lasting settlement,
but unfortunately it
didn't work out that way.
The architect of the restoration
settlement was Edward Hyde,
the Earl of Clarendon Charles and seconds
chief minister at the beginning of his
reign,
a man who'd served his father and advised
a young king throughout his period of
exile.
Now,
Clarendon was very much
a constitutional royalist
is essential idea was a return to the
constitutional situation of 1641 including
the reforms which he had supported at
the time before the outbreak of war,
which just some
modifications were necessary
in the convention parliament,
which began the restoration in 1660 all
of the acts of parliament which had been
signed by Charles the first before
the outbreak of war were confirmed.
That included all the
reforms and it included the
triennial act laying down that
or parliament should meet
at least every three years.
In addition,
royal land,
which had been confiscated during
the republic was restored to it.
Church land which had been confiscated,
was restored to the Church of England,
and indemnity was granted to the army
for all acts committed during the war.
They were paid and they were disbanded
except for a number of God's regiments
which were kept in London about the king.
In addition,
parliament passed a General Act of
indemnity and oblivion to cover both sides
during the war.
Accepting from it only the surviving
regicides 11 of those who had sign
Charles's death warrants were
executed and as you know,
the corpses of Cromwellian Dighton
were dug up and desecrated.
Okay.
So far so good.
But the so called cavalier parliament,
which was elected in 1661
to replace the convention,
parliament continued the process of the
restoration in a manner which turned out
to be far more generous to the crown
and far more vindictive to the crown's
former opponents. All military
authority was vested in the king.
The crown was granted a regular income
of over a million pounds a year from the
customs and a new tax.
The heart techs in 1662 a licensing act,
reimposed control of the press, which
had been free for the previous 20 years
and above all to further steps were taken.
First of all,
the triennial act was weakened.
It was altered to lay down.
The parliamentary sessions should take
place at least once every three years,
but there were no mandatory new elections
as had originally been intended.
In other words,
this gave the king the opportunity
to prolong an existing parliament,
which was to his taste by
simply pro ragging it and
then having it reassemble at
least once every three years.
And Charles took advantage of that
opportunity. The cavalier parliament,
very favorable to the king elected in
1661 was in fact continued without new
elections until 1668
the second major change was that the
cavalier parliament showed no willingness
to grant liberty of conscience to
dissenters as had been promised.
In 1662 of the church of
England was reestablished.
The prayer book was reintroduced
very little altered.
An Act of uniformity was
imposed on the whole kingdom.
All clergy were required to subscribe to
the act of uniformity or to be deprived
of their livings. As a result, hundreds
who couldn't in conscience subscribe,
we're deprived and a number of
additional acts were introduced against
dissenters between 60 and 61 and 1665
they were banned from holding office in
any urban corporation in 1664 they were
banned from holding religious services.
Only services of the Church of
England were permitted. A year later,
the five Mile Act banned dissenting
clergyman from living within five miles of
any corporate city places where
traditionally they had had a good deal of
strength.
Now this was not what
Charles the second wanted.
It wasn't what the Earl of Clarendon
wanted, but they accepted it.
As a result,
a large minority of the population were
forced into the position of being either
active or potential dissidents
in matters of religion.
Surveys that have been done suggest that
Protestant dissenters made up about 10%
of the entire population.
Though their strength varied a great deal
from area to area in some parts of the
kingdom, they were very thin
on the ground. The county
of structure. For example,
on the Welsh border, a survey done
in 1672 reveals very few of them.
On the other hand, in the town of
Culture Stare in Essex on the east coast,
it's thought that as much as a third
of the population were dissenters,
many of them clickers.
And then if we turn to London,
London appears to have had about a fifth
of its population favoring descent and
minority owned your fifth.
But remember in a city the size of
London that meant 100,000 people.
So the restoration had restored too much.
It had gone back too far.
It restored not only the consensual
constitutional position of 1641 but also
some of the tensions and some of the
stresses of the 1640s and it had weakened
the position of parliament
in one important respect
by modifying the triennial
act.
Well,
obviously enough religious dissenters
had good reason to be very quickly
disappointed and disillusioned
with the restoration settlement.
But more broadly,
it took some time before
tensions began to reemerge fully.
Charles, the second was welcomed back
as the restorer of order. He was young.
He was only 30.
He was tall and handsome.
He was a man who was energetic only
in his sports and his pleasures.
Uh, the fact that he hasn't had
many mistresses is very well known.
He managed to father 13
illegitimate children,
all of whom were give them the surname.
Fitzroy son of the King Fitzrovia in the
west end of London is named after one
of them, but he never managed
to have a legitimate heir.
He was happy to be king, though he
played the part well. He was intelligent.
He was shrewd.
He was affable.
He swarmed around St James's park
with his Spaniels and his mistresses.
He attended meetings at the Royal Society.
He showed his courage during the great
fire of London in 1666 when he joined in
the firefighting.
He knew he looked good in a wet shirt,
but despite all of these qualities,
Charles had no particular political
vision or strategy and perhaps that was
adjusted as well.
Can you that beneath the public
celebrations of his restoration,
the restoration had been
and in a very real sense,
remained essentially conditional and he
had no desire as he put it himself to go
on my travels again,
he was happy to be back.
Nevertheless,
if he had no particular vision,
he did have his preferences and from
time to time they got him into trouble
principle amongst them where first of all,
his admiration for the monarchy
off his cousin, King Louis,
the 14th of France,
the so called Sun King,
the absolute monarch of Europe's emergent,
great power and the very model of
monarchical magnificence displayed in his
palisade for side.
Secondly,
there was Charles his sympathy to put
it no stronger for Roman Catholicism,
the religion of his mother as a religion
which he regarded as more suitable to
monarchy
and these preferences led
him into interconnected
initiatives in foreign policy
and in matters of religion,
which were potentially alienating to
some of his subjects far more alienating
than his raffish court or
his personal debauchery.
In 1665 to seven England fought a brief
and unsuccessful naval war with the
Dutch. The second Dutch war
triggered off by commercial rivalry.
It was a deeply humiliating episode and
especially so since everyone remembered
very well.
All of a Cromwells military strength and
the triumph in the first Dutch war in
the 1650s Samuel peeps,
secretary of the navy at this time
confided to his diary repeatedly is
dissatisfaction with the manner in
which the war had been conducted is
dissatisfaction with the way in which
the king and his counsel would not attend
to business as had been done
under the previous regime.
As a result of the failures
of the second Dutch war,
the Earl of Clarendon was sacrificed as
escape goat and he was replaced with a
ministry which is known as the cabal.
After the initial letters
of the principal, Miss
Ministers, Clifford Arlington,
Buckingham, Ashley Cooper, and Lauderdale
in 60 and 70 under the cabal ministry,
Charles concluded the
Treaty of Dover with France
in its,
he agreed to ally with France in
any future war against the Dutch.
It was not popular with those in the
kingdom who saw France as the truly rising
threat of the 1660s potentially a new
Spain aiming at European dominance,
people who also saw the
Dutch as the principal,
opponents of that French hegemony
and the treaty would have been even
less popular if people had known that it
contained to secret clauses.
First of all,
Charles had agreed secretly that at an
appropriate moment he would suspend the
penal laws against Roman Catholics.
Secondly,
he had agreed with Louis that he would
himself convert to Catholicism at a
propitious moment.
In return for this,
he received again in secret a quarter
of a million pounds a year pension from
France.
Well,
in the aftermath of the Treaty of Dover
in 60 and 72 Louis the 14th declared war
on the Netherlands and invaded.
Charles issued a declaration of indulgence
in which he used his power supreme
head of the church to just suspend
the penal laws against both Protestant
dissenters and Roman Catholics and
indeed he allowed to send us to publicly
worship in licensed meeting
houses two days later,
England also war on the Dutch.
The beginning of the third Dutch war.
This war proved again
to be very unpopular,
no to bleed because it was highly
unsuccessful militarily and there was a
growing sympathy amongst the political
public with the plucky Dutch and the
young leader William of orange
standing up against the French.
The Declaration of indulgence with its
granting of a degree of religious liberty
to those other than members of the
Church of England was even more unpopular
with the Anglican dominated
cavalier parliament.
It met again in 1673 for a new session
and almost immediately attacked the
declaration of indulgence declaring
that Penal Statutes in matters
ecclesiastical cannot be suspended,
but by an act of parliament and at the
suspending power which the king had used
was innovators.
No such power said the House of Commons
was ever claimed or executed by his
predecessors.
Faced with this kind of opposition
from people who had previously been his
strongest supporters,
Charles Back Down,
he showed his characteristic unwillingness
to push his own preferences beyond
the bounds of political expediency.
The Declaration of indulgence
was withdrawn and under
the threat of withholding
supply for the war effort.
He agreed to the passage by
parliament of the test act.
The test act was an act laying down that
all officers of the crown must swear
the oath of supremacy and allegiance and
take a declaration against the Catholic
doctrine of transubstantiation and take
communion in the Church of England.
So it was a test of Anglican
religious conformity.
Prominent amongst its early victims
were, first of all, Lord Clifford,
one of Charles as chief ministers who
was a secret Catholic. And secondly,
and even more importantly,
James Duke of York, Charles,
his younger brother,
who at this point was of course
also the heir to the throne.
Since Charles and his Portuguese wife
Catherine of Braganza had had no children.
James had declared in 1673
most unpropitious Lee,
his conversion to Catholicism
under the test act,
he was excluded from high office.
Well,
this day,
barcal led to the collapse of the Cabal
Ministry and the appointment of a new
chief minister, Thomas
Osborne, the Earl of Danby,
who was fiercely Anglican that satisfied
the cavalier parliament and who was
also as it pro Dutch.
But Charles was still secretly getting
a pension from the French in return for
keeping parliament out of
session as much as possible
in 1677 when he had to call it again,
it met and tried to make the voting of
further taxes conditional upon Charles
joining the Dutch led
alliance against France.
And at this point that king resisted
successfully arguing that he allowed
parliament to prescribe
his foreign policy.
It is plain that no prince or state in
Europe would any longer believe that the
sovereignty of England rests in the crown.
So Charles took a stand on that point,
but Dan be nonetheless
succeeded in building at least
one bridge with the Dutch
when in 1677 he was able to
arrange the marriage of Mary,
the daughter of James by an earlier
marriage, Charles, his niece,
and a Protestant by upbringing.
Her marriage was arranged to
William of Orange and event,
which was to prove to be of
profound future significance.
So at this point,
Charles,
like his shrewd grandfather James the
first had proved himself flexible enough
to avoid provoking political crisis.
He knew when to give way
as well as when to stand.
But by the late 16th seventies,
anxieties were growing about the threat
of popery and arbitrary power at home as
well as abroad.
It was made worse in 1674 when the
Duke of York now a declared an openly
declared Catholic, married the
Catholic Princess Mary of Medina,
which pose the risk that there might be
the birth of a future heir to the throne
who would be brought
up as a Roman Catholic.
There was also a growing sense of distance
between the court and the country and
the growing suspicion of
the king's intentions.
It was in 1677 that Andrew Marvell
best known today as a poet,
but at that time, member of parliament
for the town of Hull in Yorkshire,
published,
um,
without putting his name on it and account
of the growth of popery and arbitrary
par in which he argued in this pamphlet
that you could discern a plot to
introduce what we,
what he described as absolute tyranny,
French slavery,
and popup idolatry.
These are the fears that were circulating
amongst Charles as opponents in
parliament.
Clearly we've been here before.
The highly combustible elements of 17th
century English political were being
mixed again and a spark
which was needed to cause.
A new explosion was provided in the
autumn of 1678 when one Titus Oates laid
allegations of a Jesse would plot to
murder King Charles in order to hasten the
succession of his brother
James to the throne.
This was the beginning of the
so called pope ish plot affair.
The tuchus Oates is wild allegations
were seriously listened to by parliament
and by the political public in general
can be explained only by the preexisting
atmosphere of suspicion,
which had been building up in the sixties
and seventies but the allegation soon
acquired greater credibility.
So Edmund Barry Godfrey,
the London magistrate who
had taken Oates's, um,
allegations was found murdered,
then a search of the
house of Prince James's,
former secretary Edward Coleman revealed
real correspondence between the Duke of
York Secretary and Jesse.
What's then there was the
revelation in December,
1678 in parliament by an aggrieved former
ambassador of the secret clauses of
the Treaty of Dover of
1670 which caused uproar.
Parliament attempted to impeach
the Earl of Danby for his share of
responsibility for oil policy and Charles
was forced a blast to dissolve the
cavalier parliament. In January, 1679
the pope of plot precipitated what
Jonathan Scott has described as the second
great crisis of Potpourri
and arbitrary par.
The exclusion crisis as it's called,
running from 60 and 79 to 1681 exclusion
crisis because it involved attempts by
parliament to exclude James Duke of York
heir to the throne from the succession.
The first exclusion parliament
met between March and May,
1679 elections to this new parliament.
The first elections held and 1661 took
place in an atmosphere of tremendous
political excitement.
When it met the Earl of Danby was sent
to the tower of London where he remained
for the next five years.
Parliament then proposed a bill to
exclude James Duke of York from the
succession and persisted
in demanding this,
despite King Charles us offer that he
would have limits put upon the powers of
appointment of any future Catholic king.
He was willing to give way to
some degree beyond that. However,
Charles was ready to resist defending
the legitimate succession to the throne
was one issue that he would fight for.
Parliament was dissolved and James was
sent off to Scotland to keep him out of
harms way.
This crisis now unleashed political
agitation and popular involvement in
politics of a kind which really hadn't
been seen since the 1640s there was
tremendous debate of the exclusion issue
in the coffee houses and taverns of
London and the other major cities.
This debate fueled by an
outbreak of pamphlets hearing,
which was possible because the licensing
act controlling the press had actually
expired in 1679 and parliament had d been
dissolved before it had time to renew
it temporarily.
The press was free again.
Mass demonstrations took place in
London calling for a new parliament.
These street demonstrations
were orchestrated by a
former member of Charles has
government,
the Earl of Shaftsbury and his friends
in the so called green ribbon club,
but they also demonstrated
genuine popular concern.
There was a real basis of popular
concern which Shaftsbury and his friends
successfully mobilized,
but the agitation wasn't all one way.
As the crisis deepened,
the emergence of two new terms in
politics took place Whigs and Tories terms
which were adopted to describe different
political positions both inside and
outside parliament over
the issue of exclusion.
The cell called wigs specialized in
mounting precessions through London at
which, which tended to culminate in
the burning of effigies of the pope.
They place great emphasis
upon the threat of popery.
They placed a great deal of emphasis
also on the threat of arbitrary power.
They talked a lot about the need
to defend England's religion,
liberties and property and
called for a new parliament,
which alone could save the day.
In their view.
The Tories on the other hand placed
their confidence in the king.
They branded the wings as
being predominantly dissenters
in sympathy religiously
as closet Presbyterians, as fermenters
of insurrection against the king,
as secret Republicans,
as a threat to the Church of England
and to England's true deputies.
They repeatedly played upon the threat
of a new 1641 a new slide into civil war.
Yeah.
Behind these insulting labels.
Wig and Tory then lay emerging political
alignments rooted in differences of
political principle and these divisions,
as I've said,
where to be found not only
amongst members of parliament,
but also permeated deeply
down through society,
beyond the political elite
to the middle sort of people.
Those who supported the
demonstrations of one side or another.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
this fever atmosphere in the late
sixties and seventies and early 16 ATS
provided the background to the
parliamentary politics of those years.
In October 60 80,
another new parliament met.
This one's usually known as the
second exclusion parliament. Again,
the House of Commons declared that it
would grant supply of money to the crown
only in return for a new exclusion.
Bill Charles promptly dissolved it in
January 60 91 and called for yet another
parliament this time to meet,
not in London,
but in the friendly city of Oxford.
Two months later,
the king was clearly playing for time.
In March 60 and 81,
the Oxford parliament met again in an
atmosphere of tremendous public agitation.
It was in the course of, of the Oxford
parliament that the incident took place,
uh, in which, um, the
king's mistress Nell Gwynne,
the actress proceeding to Oxford in
her coach in order to join the king,
found herself surrounded by an angry mob
who thought she was the Duchess of Port
Portsmith and other of charges,
Mr says,
who happened to be a Catholic now Gwen
was able to get the crowd to leave her
alone by opening the door, showing
herself and crying be still good people.
I am the Protestant Hall.
Meanwhile in Oxford,
the House of Commons still demanded the
exclusion of James Duke of York from the
succession.
Charles roundly declared that he would
not have it and he dissolved them again.
So what next?
Charles couldn't face another parliament,
but he decided to call the wigs
bluff and to brazen it out.
In the absence of a sitting parliament,
he trusted in the possibility that he
might be able to rally support in the
political nation at large,
largely by appealing to Tory
sympathizers and partly by playing on the
widespread fears that if
this agitation continued,
it might lead to another breakdown,
another 41
okay.
In April of 60 and 81 he issued a
studiously moderate declaration of his
position and ordered that it should be
read out from the pulpit of every parish
church in England,
and so it was in his declaration.
The king explained the basis of his
principled conduct in defending the
legitimate succession to the throne.
He revived memories of the breakdown into
civil war and how that war had led to
the abolition of the Church of England
to military rulership and the subjugation
of English liberties
and threats to property
and it worked.
No parliament was sitting to
focus opposition to the king.
Agitation was gradually dying down
and Charles pressed his advantage.
Hard Titus Oates was arrested
and tried for perjury.
Found guilty.
His allegations declared false and
he was punished in the pillory.
The Earl of Shaftsbury leader of
the wigs was indicted for treason.
He fled abroad where he shortly died.
Charles then began a systematic program
of calling in and remodeling the
charters of England cities as a means
of purging the corporations which
supported weeks in national politics
and thereby rendering the cities which
elected members of parliament
more politically controllable.
Between 60 and 81 and 60 and 85 51 cities
had their charters remodeled in this
way to make them more
politically manipulable. 47 more.
We're still in the pipeline.
In 60 95
Charles also permitted the intensified
prosecution of dissenters in order to
satisfy Anglican prejudices and
to cow the dissenters themselves.
The Quakers suffered especially severely
during the persecution of the early 60
[inaudible] in 1683 with the discovery
of an alleged plot against the king,
the rye house plot wig radicals were
arrested and two leading wig leaders,
Lord Russell and origin and
Sydney were brought to trial,
found guilty and executed.
Finally in 1684 Charles further
consolidated his position by defying the
triennial act under the triennial act.
He should have called a new
parliament that year. He didn't.
So Charles the second had faced
the crisis of his reign at last,
proven himself when stirred to be
politically pretty astute and he had one
in February,
1685 when the king was
suddenly incapacitated by a
stroke and then died after a
short illness.
He had never been stronger
and it was on his deathbed that at last
he found the propitious moment he had
been waiting for and
converted to Catholicism.
Okay,
well,
Charles had one by gambling that in
the absence of a sitting parliament,
which could focus opposition,
no one could face the prospect
of armed rebellion against him.
No one could face a renewal of civil war.
He had consolidated his
position by appealing to the
fears and the prejudices of
the Tory Anglican majority amongst
the political nation at large,
and he had demonstrated that a
protestant or authoritarianism was not
necessarily unacceptable to those people.
It's interesting indeed to speculate as
to whether if James the Second Charles,
his successor had continued to build
up and an enhanced royal power on that
basis.
Whether England might have become a
protestant absolute estate like Sweden or
Denmark,
not impossible,
but we'll never know because if chance a
second had had a lot in common with his
grandfather James the first James.
The second proved to be rather closer
in temperament to his father Charles the
first in a sense,
he was a better man morally
then his brother Charles,
but he also suffered far too much from
energy coupled with a catastrophic lack
of political judgment.
James couldn't leave well alone.
Initially his position was very strong.
His first parliament was Tory dominated
and it was willing to trust him despite
his Roman Catholicism Parliament was
generous to him indeed in its financial
grants.
And then in the summer of 1685 when
Charles has seconds illegitimate son,
the Duke of Monmouth, Monmouth,
landed in the west of England,
raised a small army and claimed to
be the legitimate heir to the throne.
Parliament quickly granted James the
resources for more troops to head west and
crush the rebellion swiftly
and yet,
despite this strength in
the first year of his reign,
in less than three years,
James managed to undermine his own
position with a quite staggering
comprehensiveness.
The problem was of
course James's religion.
It need not have been a
problem, but he made it. One,
he was a deeply sincere catholic
with all of the zeal of a convert.
He probably didn't intend to impose his
religion coercively upon the nation,
but he was certainly determined to
remove the disabilities of his co
religionists and to
promote their interests.
And he ductless hoped that with more
widespread conversions to Catholicism,
eventually the nation would move back
gradually in a Catholic direction.
These were not ignoble ames
from James's point of view,
but of course in the conditions
of late 17th century England,
they constituted gross political folly,
especially in the 60 [inaudible] at a
time when King Louis the 14th France had
recently revoked the toleration previously
granted under rich layer to French
Protestants and England was receiving
thousands of Protestant refugees from
Louis brutal persecution in France.
What changes needed if he was to proceed
with his intentions was to get the test
acts repealed.
Parliament clearly was
not willing to grant that,
so James turned instead to his use of
his prerogative powers and in particular
to his dispensing path.
Theoretically,
the king was permitted to
dispense particular individuals
from the penalties of
the law in special cases where rigid
enforcement of the letter of the law might
result in an injustice.
This prerogative power,
however,
did not extend to authorizing acts
which were contrary to the law.
Pure and simple. It was meant for
occasional use in special cases.
James,
his use of the dispensing power showed a
lack of respect for that distinction in
the law and was deeply provocative.
Indeed.
The manner in which it was used was
so provocative as as as to be almost
farcical in retrospect,
what one almost imagines that James,
James and his cabinet, we're meeting
every morning and asking themselves,
what can we do today,
which will really upset people?
Let's have some Catholics in the privy
council. Four of them. Okay, great.
How about making your Jesuit
confessor a member of the cabinet.
Sweet.
Let's make 250 Catholics justices of
the peace in the counties and displace
their Protestant predecessors.
Wonderful idea.
Let's upon Catholic officer's
in the militia and the army,
let's appoint a Catholic Lord Deputy
of Ireland and allow him to wreak Athol
assize the army.
Let's make an Oxford
college a Catholic seminary.
Wonderful ideas,
and he did it all.
Now, James was not so stupid as not to
realize that this policy would be deeply
alienating to Anglican support,
but he thought that he
could counterbalance that
by wooing support amongst
Protestant dissenters.
In April,
1687 he himself issued a declaration of
indulgence like his brother suspending
the penal laws against both
dissenters and Roman Catholics.
Yeah.
In some then the kings dispensing power
was being exercise with a freedom that
was clearly turning it into an
illegal suspension of the law.
The very thing which parliament
had declared against in
1673 and James appeared
to be forcing his base of support,
his natural allies amongst
Tories and staunch Anglicans.
He was forcing them to choose between
their loyalty to their church and their
loyalty to the king.
Okay.
To make matters worse.
In 1687 James embarked upon what appeared
to be a blatant attempt to pack a
future parliament for the purpose of
securing the repeal of the test acts or
justices of peace in the counties
and members of urban corporations for
parliamentary constituencies were asked
by the king to answer three questions
relating to whether or not they would
support repeal of the test acts in a new
parliament,
whether or not they would vote for those
who would support such a repeal if they
were elected to parliament,
and whether they would support
the new declaration of indulgence.
James could hardly have signaled
his intentions more clearly.
And by doing so,
he occasioned widespread alarm,
not just among Anglicans,
but also amongst the majority of the
dissenters whom he had been trying to woo.
They were not disposed to trust.
The king's good intentions
at this point,
anxieties was perhaps only contained by
expectations that this situation might
not last too long.
King James was now 55 years old,
quite a good age for the
time he still had no son.
His eldest daughter Mary.
His air was a Protestant and was
married to William of Orange in the
Netherlands.
If the king were to die soon,
then they would surely succeed
and it might well be the case.
The toleration would be achieved for
Protestant dissenters without empowering
Roman Catholics in the
way James was doing.
That may have been many people's hope,
but in the winter of 60 87 in the
spring of 60 and 88 to precipitants
transformed the situation.
First of all,
in November,
1687 it became known that Queen Mary
was pregnant and that the pregnancy was
going well.
James might then have a
Catholic air if a son was born.
Secondly,
in April,
1688 James ordered his declaration of
indulgence to be read out in all Anglican
churches.
Seven bishops of the Church of England,
including the Archbishop of Canterbury
himself petitioned against this action.
In reply,
they were indicted and tried for sedition.
The case of the seven bishops turned
on the legality of the use of the
dispensing power by the
king and when it was heard,
they were acquitted to
widespread public rejoicing.
And then in June,
1688 Queen Mary was delivered of a child,
a prince.
The young Prince James Rumors immediately
began to circulate that in fact,
the child was not the king's child,
but had been smuggled into the queen's
bed chamber secretly in a warming pan in
order to give the appearance of
the birth of an heir to the throne.
People were now so desperate they were
willing to believe stories of this kind
or pretend they did.
All of this persuaded seven
leading politicians, five
of them wigs, two of them,
Tory's including the all of Danby
Charles former chief minister,
that it was time to do something.
This was the third crisis
of popery and arbitrary par.
And in June,
1688 these seven leaders who later
became known as the immortal seven sent a
letter to William of orange expressing
their fear for their liberties,
their religion,
and their property,
and inviting him to intervene to secure
a free parliament and to investigate the
suspicious circumstances
of Prince James's birth.
William had in fact already
been anticipating the
likelihood of renewed war with
France in 1688 and he had made contingency
plans for the possible invasion of
England if as he inspect expected
James the second supported Louis,
the 14th France against him.
Louie was indeed ready to support
James in such an eventuality,
but the autumn of 60 and 88 came and no
one expected an invasion later than that
because of the prevalence of adverse
winds in the English Channel.
By September,
1688 then Louis of France considered
himself free of that threat and obligation
and he moved his troops south in order
to invade the Palatinate in Germany.
The first steps in a renewed war.
This freed William of orange from fear
of an immediate French attack upon the
Netherlands.
In October 60 and 88 he
issued a declaration that he
was coming over in order to
preserve and maintain
the established laws,
liberties and customs of England,
and to investigate the birth of
the prince. On the 1st of November,
he sailed was carried down the channel,
but by what was later known
as the Protestant wind.
A wind blowing unusually in the
right direction for his purposes.
He was carried down the channel to land
at Tall Bay in the west of England on
the 5th of November,
1688 a very propitious day
faced with this invasion,
King James initially joined his army.
It's Saulsbury in the west country,
but inexplicably lost his
nerve and withdrew to London.
James was no coward. He'd fought
very bravely, uh, in his youth,
but for some reason he lost his nerve
and withdrew his army's leaders.
Went over to William and joined him.
Risings also began to take
place in some provincial cities.
The Earl of Danby for example,
Seized York with parties of
the not the Yorkshire Gentry.
At this point,
King James sent his family abroad for
safety and on the 11th of December,
himself attempted to flee throwing the
great seal of England into the River
Thames. Before doing so in an
effort to paralyze the government,
which needed the great
seal for various acts,
James was captured by a fishing boat on
his way out of England and returned to
London where he was held in
custody until the 20th of December.
When he again escaped
probably by collusion on the
part of William supporters
who allowed him to escape.
Indeed, his escape was vital.
What would they have
done if James had stayed?
There had been back in the position of
1648 of negotiations with Charles the
first,
but with James Gone,
the political process could
proceed in his absence.
He was allowed to escape to France
and on the 24th of December,
1688 and assembly of the nobility asked
William and Mary to take up the reins of
government the way it was prepared
for a refashioning of government,
which was to proceed over the next two
decades and which was to transform the
British constitution.
But I returned to that after the break.
Next time,
we need to look at some other developments
which were taking place in the late
17th century. The extraordinary
economic growth of that period.